お前ら、
（真顔）
俺にドッキリを仕掛けてくれ。
はじめさん！
僕に…そんなことできません…。
ん…んん～///・・・・・・・（喘ぎ）
ﾎｯ
はぁぁぁぁぁああああ甘えてんじゃなあ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛い!!（発狂）
いいか、
俺はいつもドッキリを仕掛ける側だ。
誰も俺にドッキリを仕掛けてくれない!
そうだろ…。
確かに…言われてみれば…!
ﾊｯ…!ふざけるなあああああ!!
ということだ。
俺は今から睡眠に入る。
お前たち、
俺に特大のドッキリを仕掛けてくれ。
なんでもしていい。何でも好きなことをしていいぞ。
燃やｓ…いや、燃やしちゃダメだ。
痛いのもよし、/////苦しいのもよし/////、
お前たちがやりたい最高のドッキリを
俺に仕掛けてくれ。
分かりました!
はじめさんの為なら…罪を犯してでもドッキリを仕掛けます!
布団で待ってる...
ﾁｯ･･･(怒)
SHI☆NE☆YO
言うな。
そうして俺たちは、後輩YouTuberとして、はじめしゃちょーに寝起きドッキリを仕掛けることになった。
ふん、この俺があの馬鹿共のドッキリに引っかかるとは。
100年早いわ。
震えて眠れ!俺!
ｺｫｰｯｹｺｫｰｯｺｫｫｫｫｫｫ!!
音楽♪
ｼﾞｬｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧﾝwwwwwww(おはようございまあああす!!)
おおぅ///
おはようございまーす！
ﾊﾞｧﾝ!!
おはようございます！
せーのーで、はいいいいぃぃぃぃ!!!!
おはようございます!
おはようございます。
出禁。
このドッキリの内容はですね。
寝起きに、いろんな感じを出させるってドッキリなんですけど
まず一つ目、ﾄﾞﾜｰﾝ、うるさい。
うるさい、うるさっかたでしょ。
熱いと寒い。ﾋﾞｬｯとかけたんですよ。
熱湯と冷水をﾋﾞｬｯてかけました。
で、次に、痛い。
ハリセンでﾊﾟﾁｺｰﾝ☆と叩きましたね。
で次に、楽しい。
シャボン玉でこう、楽しいな゛ーって。
で、次に、汚い。
ﾊﾟｧｰﾝｯ☆
で最後に…。